hello and welcome to insight Germany my
guest today is an opera singer from
South Africa there are not many
opportunities to further an operatic
career there so she came to Europe
originally in 2005 and for the last
three years has been thrilling audiences
with her beautiful voice at the Opera
House in Stuttgart here in Germany who
Meza Matt akiza was brought up in a
Township in South Africa's capital Cape
Town at the end of the apartheid era and
is now one of the most talked about
young Sopranos in the Opera world thanks
for joining us thank you should ask you
because I I know we couldn't have a pre
talk as your voice all right yes it is
it's good better much much better I had
a small sore throat fetching towards our
cold but now it's fun oh good um now I
said in the introduction there's not
much chopper in South Africa there is
Opera in South Africa there is but not
much not as much as Europe of course but
there's plenty of music and I possibly
say more than in Europe and that
everybody seems to make music in South
Africa I would and so I wonder what were
your first memories of singing my first
memories of singing were church music
and choral music in school so those two
were my first memories and then from the
radio um R&B or soul music some American
artists yeah yeah oh okay
and I believe music is very much in the
family are you related to Todd magic you
see he is a distant relative of mine and
I know his wife who I met in a in in a
wedding I was singing a wedding in and
his wife was there so she came after the
show and introduced herself to me and
told me about her husband and wanted to
know where my family came from
we met in Cape Town and so we made the
connection that we both came from Queens
down in the Eastern Cape that's where my
family came from before they went to
Jonas burg and to Cape Town so yes he's
a he's longer native well known was
quite a well-known jazz pianist and
composer jazz pianists and composers
well yes and a teacher he was a
mathematics and English teacher oh okay
now we're going to hear you in a report
in a minute we're going to hear you
explain how you sing in the
extraordinary way of the is it the ho
ho's our language it's Casa I won't try
to say that I don't think shall I try
Hafsah there you are
did I a bit quicker we'll be perfect
Haase yeah yeah get it yeah
awesome we we're gonna we're gonna see
how you do that actually in our report
in a minute so I don't want to ask you
about that but what is so special about
the language itself in that you put in
our questionnaire the worst thing about
living in Germany is missing your leg so
um not the singing language but just the
spoken language what is so strong is it
the only language that has these things
that has the clicks no actually it's not
the only language that has the clicks
the history of South Africa is that most
of us black South Africans came from the
north
we found the Bushmen the cousins and the
hottentots in the South there were some
intermarriages and sharing of cultures
and we got the clicks from them we the
bundles didn't really have clicks so we
only got the C Q and X which and you mix
those with ours we have a or o are a
click or book I'd like a couple
identical to and when the Bushmen speak
you hear no vowels you hear only
and they understand that's all you hear
and they understand
and that is even more frustrating for me
while other people are fascinated by
course I am fascinated by that and it's
also a tonal language which means that
if you sing if you say something and
with a going up at the end it can mean
one thing but if it comes down it can
mean another thing yeah yes so what
happens ah leading up to my question
what happens when you sing in the
language because surely you have to keep
to the note mm doesn't perhaps the wrong
meaning come and not necessarily because
then there's the context and also if the
composer is good they will kind of try
to put the stress wait supposed to be
okay I asked that because I know in
Chinese that is the case yes and I've
spoken to a Chinese singer about this
and and the Chinese audiences accept
that the text is wrong but it isn't they
realize what yeah the text is about yeah
they have to sing the note yes yeah but
that's not the same than in your
language just a little bit it's not so
audible okay yeah so let's find out more
about my guests career so far here her
wonderful singing voice too and she'll
show us first of all the unique way of
singing in her native tongue
and that's your old school that's my
older daughter yes do you have anything
to do with that school is that the
school what does a choir isn't that
there's a choir I sang him that choir
that's cool but is that the choir on
your CD no the play on the city is the
choir from Uganda and they happen to be
in London around that time and my
producer Dominic v made a talk with them
if they'll be interested in the
collaboration and they were up for it
and we did it it was also cheaper
because we didn't have to fly people
from from South Africa to London and
they were going to be in London around
that time but also I'd like to give
something back to them and because I
really enjoyed working with them and
also they have a particular story
because most of them are orphans mmm you
know their parents died in the wars in
Uganda and so I would like to help them
raise money so I could perform with them
sometime is that going to happen yes
it's going to happen in the future yeah
and I should mention the CD we've got a
signed copy of the album voice of hope
to give away just right - is it in sight
at DWD e saying you'd like to be entered
into the draw and we'll do just that and
pick one of out of the hat in a couple
of weeks time want to talk a bit more
about the album we've explained the
clicks and I can't do it how can you
learn it actually yes you can you can
but on the album you sing classical
operatic Ahrens yes and hoser folk songs
how does the vocal technique differ or
doesn't it um you know this album was a
big experiment for me because I had
never sang many of the African pieces
before and they were never arranged in a
classical form and so you'd suddenly
find yourself having to sing
something you never sang in tune now it
has it had to be in tune because you
could sing some notes flatter or
sharpened it wouldn't matter because
everyone sings this song Oh everyone
knows them in a much more not correct
way you know yeah yeah and so that was a
bit difficult to do actually and also I
was a little bit worried that what would
sort of against think about it because
it's not as they know it they are being
sang by someone who's trained
classically classically and also there's
now an orchestra
what would the response is like what did
they it's not out yet in South Africa
even the city too many people in South
Africa and actually they do like it you
know they say it's different but they
like the concept of the whole thing
together so yes so no I mean this um
this is I think three Puccini and Mozart
but there's lots of South African songs
yes yes and one one one famous occasion
where you saying The Clique song was at
the wedding of Prince Albert of Monaco
to Charlene Wittstock from South Africa
yeah that must have been extraordinary
to be didn't know did she you know I
didn't know that she didn't know I heard
after the whole thing that she she
didn't know so it was a gift for her
yeah from him I think a secret gift from
him now I think more than half the songs
I don't know a lot of the songs on the
album are either Miriam Makeba 's or
ones made famous by this great South
African singer and civil rights lead why
was that two reasons first was the fact
that she is known in Europe and so not
all the songs will be new to the
European audience so people can easily
access access the songs through knowing
essence but they will hear them now in a
different version get my friends in
France they were telling me that
like and patapata we're hit in France at
some point I think in Germany - I don't
know which one whether it was pata pata
or Malaika but to give people something
that they already know but also done in
a in a different way and also to enter
the market with something a bit
different because if you're an opera
singer what do you sing what do you put
in your album if you're not singing the
whole opera you were seeing areas and
and songs so songs which are known by
people already so it was just creating
something different it was an experiment
and it was the first album for myself
and I I learned a lot you know as I had
never recorded before yeah let's go back
to your childhood um if I can find a
picture here now yes where is this this
is because first of all we should have a
map because we had some time finding out
where you bought you're born in Eastern
Cape Province yes at ladyfriend a
different yes at least I pronounced that
one wrong yeah lady Fred because it's a
European it hasn't got any cliques in it
no okay and here's a lovely picture you
sent us I wanted to tell us who this is
this that's my grandmother yeah and
that's my brother who is two years
younger than myself and we were I think
it wasn't longer one of the townships
close to Cape Town yeah cuz you your
parents split up sadly and yes maybe to
the townships they did we lived in the
Eastern Cape my mother came from
Queenstown and she got pregnant with me
after being with my father for about two
months and that also created problems
because my father could not did not
expect that someone who he was with only
for two months was pregnant and it was
not an easy time for my mother then but
eventually they got married but after
about three four years things didn't go
well
so that meant my mother left left first
and my father not want us to to go with
my mother so my grandmother the lady
there came to fetch us in haste in Cape
to Cape Town she worked as a domestic
worth she was a domestic worker in in
Cape Town already and so she moved her
family
bit by bit from the Eastern Cape to Cape
Town so your father didn't sort of
desert you he wanted to keep you as well
in the beginning he wanted to do that
but once my mother took us to Cape Town
then he he wanted nothing to do with
this and you were in the townships I
mean you explained again in that report
you saw some pretty horrendous things I
mean it was the school of hard knocks
wasn't it right it was you know the
looking back you just think how strange
can life be and you never know I mean
you cannot choose you'll never choose
your parents or where you will be born
and today you think they are people who
are in places like Pakistan going
through horrible things going through
the women when I say that on television
I just think about the children how they
must be feeling in this chaotic in this
chaotic existence that they have there
and although it was not brought in the
same scale but it's it's the same
feeling the chaos things which are
abnormal but you have to see and what
does that do to you and and you you have
to find out as you grow yeah does it
does it make you more driven I mean and
when I think that the fact that you know
your South African there's not a lot of
offer you are now a well-known opera
singer in a top Opera House and to
getting there which we haven't we won't
be able to tell that entire story but we
will tell a lot of it I hope it is quite
a journey so do you think that was that
an advantage of such a tough upbringing
well sometime you're tough does it make
you driven ah
am i driven am I really driven I think I
just told myself with whatever little I
have I just need to move on in life and
I I think for myself most of the time so
if I'm told by my family this and this
and that I think mm-hmm no yes
and I move on with my I make my own
rules most of the time I think growing
up there what it really made was it gave
me some kind of awareness of the things
that happen in the world you know and
how you can make things better for for
people I helped in my little modest ways
people wine-cellar figures maybe with
the school fee there or look after my
grandmother pay for someone to look
after her by medication for this person
help a person who has a project I don't
have lots of money but whatever little I
give I see that it makes a difference so
I'm aware of these things and where I
can help with a little that I can maybe
it has made me a little bit driven but
also I never accepted the fact that
because I was a black person in South
Africa that I was inferior this was for
me a big joke yes the the my
circumstance was inferior compared to
the white South Africans and that was
created no it was not a natural thing
and moving to Europe also helped me with
connecting with Europeans so-called
white people in a kind of way to
understand them to see the differences
the system the different system that was
used in South Africa how false it was
and how false it wanted to oppress
people and you were growing up in a time
of change because if I've got my maths
right you must have been about 10
when Mandela Nelson Mandela came out of
jail said about Rives that's about right
do you remember that that must have been
I remember that I remember because also
he became the first president in 1994
yeah four years later four years later
so you would have been a teenager then a
teenager so I think I followed a lot of
things when I was young I think I was
much more observant of what was
happening and I had many questions as
well as a child and I think as a child
maybe I was much more interested in
things than I am now or my mind was much
more open hmm I could tell that this was
not okay this is not good you know very
Le hmm well Mandela was obviously the
father of the nation as he's called he
was around for a long time but temp
let's recall the rather sad day back in
December 2013 when the news was broken
that Nelson Mandela had passed away
my guest is premieres on matshikiza from
South Africa an opera singer here in
Europe now do you think his legacy his
legacy lives on that is it successful
hard question very hard well you know
when you have a person who has a bigger
vision I don't think anyone who has that
can finish it it's always up to people
you know to to no one ever finishes
their work people have to take over and
and continue it um at this moment there
are problems in South Africa politically
we have a lot of mismanagement by our
government and corruption and I think
that needs to be fixed that is the
problem mmm people in South Africa
actually we're
so divided about Mandela black people
thought that some not all they thought
that they didn't get freedom that they
were cheated and but then Nelson Mandela
said but if in in in a position like
that one needs to make compromises but
think about the bigger picture how South
Afghans can live together peacefully and
it's now twenty years and things have
been going a little bit down and now I
am hopeful because everyone is suddenly
tuned into what is happening in the
country everything is out the corruption
the mismanagement and people are talking
about it it can seem from someone who's
outside that there are troubles and
there's chaos but I think we need this
chaos so that we plan a better way to
move forward and if we don't we will all
perish
you know the inequality in South Africa
is too high and it's not managed and the
youth unemployment
it's about said something percent I
think and that is very high so people
need to do something about it not to
only talk about Mandela and his legacy
and to say maybe that his way was a
peaceful way of saying South Africa
belongs to everyone who lives in it so
make the best out of it for everyone and
if you don't you all perish ok let's
talk about Mozart because there's a
connection if I may be so bold Mozart's
your favorite composer well you tell me
what's so special about Mozart and then
I think what's at teach his discipline
but I didn't sing a lot of Monsod before
when I was starting and then I started
to sing what that and I thought oh my
god it's so difficult but you can create
beauty by doing very little and by
concentrating on the details of the
music then going with the passion with
with the flow so that's what I like
about Mozart and the beauty of it that
comes out of that you also said though
or you once said Mozart is that is best
when he's writing about forgiveness and
reconciliation and that's my [ __ ] yes do
you think so I mean you know because
that's what me does that strike a note
with uh South Africa yes yes it did
strike a note with me the passages where
when someone is asking for forgiveness
you know they become so beautiful and
this I liked about tinea and there's
that I'm thinking the Truth and
Reconciliation Commission in South
Africa yes you studied you came to
London on a scholarship study the Royal
Academy of Music Royal College the Royal
College I am I know how terrible that is
to say I was at the Gilderoy Oh will
that will have to cut that out and start
again the Royal College of Music not the
Royal Academy I do baby pom if you
studied in London one of the things you
did when you didn't unfinish Mozart
opera to's Aida yeah yes how much of
that was Mozart's I don't know much
about it um no it was it was a little
bit that was not matzot it was the
finale of the second act but really most
of it was not that music okay just want
to go back to your childhood a little
bit because I did I can't not show this
picture this is so cute and it intrigues
me you talking about the townships you
you had to have school uniforms there
yes we had school uniforms but that was
not a school uniform actually it was a
church there but because you see my
brother wearing as a school trousers
because he didn't have proper church
trousers so he used the same trousers
for for school and church and a cricket
sweater
yes I see that's vision yeah but you you
actually didn't go straight into music
you were going to be a surveyor weren't
you yes I studied quantity surveying for
two years which was yeah
very boring haha very very boring it was
actually not my idea it was a teachers
idea but I because I had good grades in
math and science when I was in high
school and so he thought that music
would not pay off it was not so secure
and he wanted me to have a secure life
and not waste my brain on music but you
hung around the music department yes I
did I used to care was always there it
was always there yes I always wanted to
do music we talked about sayyida briefly
I wanted this show and and another
picture of this is you in Stuttgart
I think is the point to ask about opera
in in Stuttgart this is a modern it's a
modern and we are doing foul stuff that
was foul stuff yeah we always do modern
operas actually interested cut well you
lead me on very well there because there
is a tendency to do a lot of operas in
modern clothing and modern ideas do you
like that do you think it's good or I
want I always wonder whether the opera
singers themselves feel a bit uneasy
being in a if you like in a short skirt
and a suit or something when they're
singing music that is 300 years old
it was hard for me in the beginning I
never I never thought I would do
something like that before going to
study it but what can be difficult more
difficult than the clothing is when the
interpretation of what you think you
know about the Opera is suddenly not
that so sometimes if you have to use
your emotions in a different way from
what means what the music required or
requires from you that can make it very
difficult more than the clothing oh
really yes and it happens a lot and
it's a challenge yeah you feel there is
a sort of German style of opera ban or
it well
the Reggie Theatre where the director
have their own interpretation of the
Opera it's it's most of the time very
different from what is written in the
music oh you could be in a total
different setup no nothing to do with
the story really I think it's time to
have a look at stuck now let's have a
look at some of the delights of my
guests hometown here in Germany are you
a you a jazz fan or a pop fan or do you
listen to other music oh yes I do
I listen mostly to embark on its it's a
south african zulu type of music and I
have I love it more but I'm in Europe
you know yes it's funny noise absence as
I had it all the time when I was in
South Africa though I was not I cannot
say I was not really keen on it I still
liked it but now I love it more I play
it every day a little bit of pop a
little bit of R&B a bit of chairs yes no
and do you love Berlin as you said in
our questionnaire because again you
don't live here I don't live here so we
I mean you live in took that but why why
did you put down as Berlin as your top
town because on my visits to Berlin a
fist at Frankfurt Hamburg Munich where
else and some other places but what I
love about Berlin is that I find the
people except for the history of Berlin
which is fascinating where people here
are much more interested in what is
happening currently and they are also
interested in new things they accept
your things there they are explorers and
this is what I love about this city it's
mostly the people who make cities yeah
sure sure do you remember what you wrote
for the best kept secret in Germany I
don't humor perhaps yes yes did I did I
really did you should sense of humor
sense of humor I think we should talk
about because the cliche isn't though
that the jobs rather door or and not too
serious okay before I came to Germany
that's all I heard about Germans and of
course it's not easy to get under their
skin but once you get to know them they
have one of the most amazing humors in
the world I really enjoy it humor yeah
no it's very true yeah the best thing
about living in Germany er
I completely agree with us the health
system yeah it's extraordinary isn't it
yeah um and we have have to bring this
up with there's just a bit of examples
there in the report on Stuttgart you're
not very happy with the cooking
no now are we talking about the food you
eat or about the way they cook what they
cook Oh
for instance sorry you're not gonna get
away so what you don't like is the Daath
no the sausages and the spaetzle and I
am not I'm not so known on this so what
do you eat I mean you live what do you
eat all the time
they have vegetables lots of different
fresh be your vegetables so if you
become have you become a vegetarian in
Germany I am more of a vegetarian I'm
not really much different but I really
prepare meat at home actually only when
my mother was visiting I prepared meat
maybe three or four times but she was
also surprised you don't eat a lot of
meat does it no one more question I want
to ask you about
before we go is you've recorded the
South African national anthem why just
for fun
really yes did you know it was written
by Welshman actually when I was doing
the research I had to research a few
things so that's when I knew huh but
before not okay so we've nearly finished
um what's next for you you gonna stay in
Stuttgart
despite the food Oh what's coming up I
mean we've got the album here wonderful
album um I'm staying stood got for the
next two years but I'll be on and off in
and out sorry I'll be in and out of [ __ ]
cut yeah doing concerts and some new
products will you do concerts of purely
hos our music or will it be always a
make mixture always a mixture yeah yeah
always but I'm going to do more
classical music concert and then put a
few songs
unlike the CD No so it will be more
classical and a little bit of South
African songs well we wish you lots of
luck a little career thank you very much
for being on our show today I know
you've been a bit poorly but we came
where you came and told us lots of
interesting things cool meza much akiza
thank you very much and thank you for
watching don't forget to write to us
insight at DWG if you'd like being the
draw vertical mazes solo album here sign
on the side here voice of hope it's
called by promesa Matshikiza see you
next week up high